التحسين الكلاسيكي خطوة أساسية في الخوارزميات الكمية الكلاسيكية
زي variational quantum eigensolver أو تعلم الآلة الكمي.
بس في الغالب بيكون صعب تقليل
دوال معقدة في فضاءات ذات أبعاد عالية.
أنا Victoria Lipinska، وفي الفيديو ده هنستكشف
أساليب التحسين الكلاسيكية للخوارزميات الكمية الكلاسيكية.
مسائل التحسين مش سهلة.
لما عدد المعاملات يزيد، بيزيد معاه عدد التوليفات الممكنة
للقيم، وبيزيد بشكل أسي.
في الشطرنج مثلاً، في 64 خانة
وكل لاعب عنده 16 قطعة، بعد ما كل لاعب يحرك قطعة واحدة
في 400 وضع مختلف. وبعد حركتين في 72,084 وضع،
وحوالي 9 مليون بعد ثلاثة وحوالي
280 مليار بعد أربع حركات.
لو وصلنا لـ 40 حركة بس، عدد الأوضاع الممكنة
بيُقدَّر بحوالي عشرة أس 120.
لو حبيت تلعب لعبة مثالية لازم تستعرض كل الأوضاع الممكنة
وهذه الزيادة الهائلة معناها إن مراجعة
كل وضع على حدة مش عملي خالص.
ممكن نحل ده بتقسيم المشكلة لمشكلتين فرعيتين أصغر.
أولاً، نحدد إيه الأوضاع في لوحة الشطرنج
اللي ممكن تظهر في خطوات جاية من لعبتنا.
وهنسمي ده الفضاء الجزئي اللي نهتم بيه.
وثانياً، بناءً على الفضاء ده، نحدد إيه أفضل حركة.
وهنسميها أفضل حركة.
في التشبيه ده، البحث الأولي في الفضاء الجزئي اللي نهتم بيه
يقابل خوارزمية التحسين الكلاسيكية عندنا.
بعد ما يتحدد الفضاء الجزئي ده،
خوارزمية كمية في الغالب بتكون مسؤولة عن إيجاد أفضل حركة،
بناءً على هذا الفضاء.
خلينا نبدأ بمعاملة واحدة بس،
theta، اللي بتحدد دالة التكلفة اللي عايزين نحسنها.
لو رسمنا الدالة، هتبان حاجة زي كده،
على محور X عندنا قيم المعامل theta
وعلى محور Y عندنا دالة التكلفة.
خد في بالك إن دالة التكلفة ممكن تكون تكلفة مالية حقيقية
عايزين نقللها، أو زي ما بيحصل كتير في variational quantum
eigensolver، ممكن تكون طاقة بتتقلل بشكل طبيعي.
هدفنا هو إننا نلاقي الـ theta
اللي يقابل أقل تكلفة.
بنبدأ بقيمة أولية لـ theta، وفي كل خطوة تحسين
بنلاقي theta جديد يقلل التكلفة أكتر.
يبدو إننا عارفين بسهولة إيه الاتجاه اللي نمشي فيه على الرسم لو قدرنا نشوفه.
بس الصعوبة في التحسين إننا في الحقيقة مش شايفين ده.
إحنا بنعرف التكلفة بس، وده جزء صغير من الصورة الكاملة،
بعد ما نحسب الدالة عند الـ theta المختار.
ده هو الأسلوب العام اللي شغال بيه التحسين.
المحسِّن بياخد عينات من المعاملات theta ويحسب التكلفة.
وزي ما تقدر تتخيل، اختيار theta بشكل عشوائي لإعادة رسم
كل تضاريس الدالة مش كفء خالص.
بدل كده، المحسِّنات الذكية بتعمل حاجة تانية وهي حساب
التدرج للدالة في كل خطوة.
بالطريقة دي المحسِّن بيعرف إيه الاتجاه على الرسم
اللي المفروض يمشي فيه علشان يلاقي أقل تكلفة.
لما التدرج يبقى صفر، الخوارزمية بتوقف،
وبيتم إيجاد الحد الأدنى.
الحد الأدنى ده ممكن ما يكونش الحد الأدنى العالمي.
ممكن يكون حداً أدنى محلياً،
يعني هو أصغر قيمة لدالة التكلفة في المنطقة المجاورة
بس مش على طول كل نطاق theta.
في حالة معامل واحد، ده ممكن يحصل بالتأكيد.
بس كلما زاد عدد المعاملات،
كلما بقت الدالة أكتر تعقيداً.
حتى في حالة معاملين بس، عندنا سطح،
وفي حالة أربعة، مش قادرين نرسمها أصلاً.
زي ما في مثال الشطرنج، استعراض كل الاحتمالات
بيبقى مستحيلاً بسرعة.
واضح إننا بيكون صعب نقلل
دوال معقدة في فضاءات معاملات ذات أبعاد عالية.
بس علشان نجيب نتايج معقولة، إحنا عايزين التحسين الكلاسيكي
يكون سريع ودقيق في نفس الوقت.
وكمان لازم يكون قادر يتعامل مع الضوضاء،
اللي هيكون ليها تأثير كبير في أجهزة الكمبيوتر الكمي القريبة المدى.
خوارزميات التحسين الكلاسيكية ممكن تتقسم بشكل عام
لفئتين - البحث المباشر والطرق القائمة على التدرج.
الطرق القائمة على التدرج تحتاج معلومات عن تدرج
الدالة أثناء عملية التحسين.
وده ممكن يتحسب تحليلياً
أو يتقرب بحساب الفروق المحدودة.
طرق البحث المباشر مش بتستخدم معلومات التدرج
وبتلجأ لاستراتيجيات تانية لتقليل دالة التكلفة.
من أكتر خوارزميات التحسين استخداماً
في مجال الحوسبة الكمية هي المحسِّنات التالية.
COBYLA اختصار لـ Constrained Optimization By Linear Approximation
وهي خوارزمية تحسين خالية من التدرج.
SLSQP هي Sequential Least Squares Programming،
خوارزمية تحسين قائمة على التدرج.
وبتستخدم متجه اضطراب عشوائي
لحساب تدرج تقريبي لدالة التكلفة في نفس الوقت.
في بيئة خالية من الضوضاء، محسِّنات زي COBYLA
وSLSQP اتضح إنها بتتقارب أسرع من SPSA.
المحسِّنات الكلاسيكية عندها معاملاتها الخاصة
اللي تقدر تحددها لحالات معينة، زي مثلاً حجم الخطوة.
في العادة ممكن تلاقيها في التوثيق المتعلق
بالمحسِّن المحدد.
بنشجعك تراجع قائمة المراجع في الأسفل للمقارنة بين
أحدث المحسِّنات الكلاسيكية.
خلينا نستكشف ظاهرة تانية مرتبطة
بالتحسين الكلاسيكي للـ circuit الكمية ذات المعاملات.
زي ما شفنا قبل كده، تلاشي تدرج دالة التكلفة ممكن يشير
إن المحسِّن وقع على هضبة مستوية بدون أي معالم مميزة، اللي بتُسمى
"الهضبة الجرداء".
الهضبة الجرداء ممكن تكون نتيجة عوامل كتير.
تدرج دالة التكلفة المقابل لـ circuit كمية
بمعاملات مُهيَّأة بشكل عشوائي
بيتناقص بشكل أسي نحو الصفر مع زيادة عدد الـ qubits.
وده لأن الفضاء الكمي اللي بيستكشفه المحسِّن
بيكبر بشكل أسي لما بيزيد عدد الـ qubits.
الطرق اللي ممكن نتعامل بيها مع المشكلة دي تشمل تقليل عدد المعاملات
وبالتالي بُعد الفضاء الأساسي.
طريقة تانية للتفكير في أصل مشكلة الهضبة الجرداء
هي الطبيعة غير المخصصة للـ circuit ذات المعاملات
في مواجهة فضاء معاملات ضخم بشكل أسي.
تصميم الـ circuit بطريقة مصممة خصيصاً للمسألة
اللي بنتعامل معاها ممكن يكون حلاً جيداً.
بالإضافة لفضاء المعاملات الأسي اللي بيسبب الهضاب الجرداء،
ظواهر فيزيائية تانية ممكن تولدها كمان:
الضوضاء وفقدان الترابط الكمي الموجودين في تجارب الحوسبة الكمية،
والقدرة التعبيرية الكلية للـ circuit ذات المعاملات،
أو اللاتموضع ودرجة التشابك الكمي لدالة التكلفة المُنمذَجة.
لا تزال التعامل مع هذه التحديات منطقة بحث نشطة.
بعد ما راجعنا المكونات الأساسية لـ VQE،
هنلخص الخوارزمية في الفيديو الجاي.